In the last 50 years we have revolutionized
the world with electronics by exploiting a
fundamental property of electrons -- their
charge.
Now researchers are working towards the next
leap forward in technology using another fundamental
property of electrons -- their spin.
The field is called spintronics, -- a portmanteau
of spin transport electronics.
The idea is to use an electron’s spin in
much the same way we use its charge.
Electronics today encode information by using
electrical currents to represent 1s and 0s.
If the current is on and electrons are flowing,
it represents a 1.
If the current is off, it’s a 0.
Electrons themselves can have spins in two
orientations, up or down.
So instead of on or off representing ones
and zeroes, up or down spins can be used to
encode information.
Spintronics would have several advantages
over traditional electronics.
Instead of using semiconductors to control
the flow of electrons, spin can be read with
common materials like aluminum and copper.
This method could be faster and more reliable,
since spin can be changed quickly and doesn’t
go away with a loss of power.
And spintronics would need less power to begin
with, since it takes less energy to change
an electron’s spin than it does to maintain
a current.
Spintronics have been applied to traditional
electronics since the late ‘90s, when it
was discovered that controlling the spin of
electrons in a hard drive could allow for
more sensitive read heads and therefore open
up more storage space.
This tech is being applied to computer RAM
for extreme applications like in aircraft
because of its reliability when exposed to
cosmic rays, but it may replace flash memory
in SD cards one day soon.
And scientists are exploring how heat and
electrical currents affect the way electrons
move and create spin currents for use in future
spintronic applications.
In another 50 years, who knows what advancements
spintronics will bring!
Before you leave, don’t forget to click
subscribe!
For more on particle spin, check out Trace’s
video on quantum teleportation to see how
we can make use of spinning photons too!
Did you know that “spinning” electrons
aren’t actually spinning, it just seems
that way from how they move?
Confusing, but cool!
Thanks for watching, I’ll see you next time
on Seeker!